imagine a soldier the size of an insect
the ultimate secret weapon you give that
like powers to everyone it's going to be
chaos so how do we stop him I know a guy
Scott I've been watching you for a while
you're different and I believe everyone
deserves a shot at redemption to you
absolutely my days are breaking into
places and stealing stuff are over
what do you want me to do I want you to
break into a place and steal some stuff
make sense are you ready to become the
hero now this suit has power
you have to learn how to control it
and these are your greatest allies
you're kind of cute
when you're small you have superhuman
strength
you like a bullet
so you need to know how to punch you
wanna show me on a bunch show me how to
punch that's how you punch you tried to
hide your soup for me now it's gonna
blow up in your face and destroy
everyone you care about
I get out of here
did you think you could stop the future
you're just a thief
a man man I know wasn't my idea
you